nobody covers the Browns better than
Mary Kay cabin the Browns meet writer
for the Cleveland Plain Dealer it's
always something there in Cleveland and
we were just talking about those Baker
Mayfield commercials how are those
playing in Cleveland Mary Kay well
actually I think they're getting great
reviews but it would have been a lot
better if he had one this year I think
the bloom is off the rose a little bit
with Baker right now and he needs to get
the fans back on his side
the Browns missed the playoffs this year
because of what coaching i 100%
Danielson that it was coaching they
picked the wrong head coach and he just
was not able to get anything out of this
offense and they really under it and it
just should not have been you can't have
Nick Chubb Kareem Hunt Odell Beckham jr.
Jarvis Landry Baker Mayfield and not be
in the playoffs right now
when did you start to sense this Mary
Kay very early on I was very concerned
very very early on in the process that
this was not going to go well and
unfortunately that was proven correct
but I had grave concerns from the day
they hired him really yeah because I
watched it and and I've been around
these teams and sometimes you bring in
personalities and when you have a young
coach and a young quarterback and you
have big personalities it can be a
recipe for disaster like you're not it's
not like Julio Jones is your wide
receiver and he doesn't say anything he
just shows up and acts like a Hall of
Fame wide receiver I just wonder what
this team is going to look like next
year and we'll get to that in a moment
but is this an attractive job right now
I think it is a very attractive job
right now and I can tell you that the
candidates that they are interviewing
are so excited about this job at least
most of them are really ready to jump at
this chance if they get the opportunity
and why is that well for many reasons
including the fact that this is still a
very talented roster and again it just
needed a firm hand some leadership some
great coaching and all of these guys I'm
sure
believe that they can be that guy
alright is who's the leading candidate
right now you know I don't know who the
leader in the clubhouse is right now
they're playing it close to the vest I
would have to think that Kevin Stefanski
because he was Paul D Podesta's man last
year but he's got to be a finalist in
this thing I don't know if he's the
favorite because I think there's a lot
of sentiment in the building for josh
mcdaniels
and everything that he brings to the
table including the fact that you know
he is from here this is his dream to
coach the Cleveland Browns and he's
interviewed with this team two other
times he's got head coaching experience
so I would think that those two guys
probably will be amongst the finalists I
don't know who will end up with it but I
don't know there's just something about
the fact that Kevin Stefanski thought
that he blew away everyone in the
building last year and then came back
and strengthened his resume here I just
think that's something to keep an eye on
we'll Odell Beckham jr. be with the team
next year great question for right now
I'm going to say yes but I think it's
something that will be discussed in the
offseason not just amongst themselves
but but with Odell with his agent I
think everyone needs to put their heads
together and make sure that this is an
equitable situation for everyone and I
preface this by saying I don't know
Odell Beckham jr. I know he's extremely
talented
I would not want that situation if I'm a
head coach as much of a luxury as he is
I still think there are
I got a young quarterback who I thought
went out of his way to try to please
people trying to please those wide
receivers and that's not what you want
in that position and I just it it makes
me nervous going into it would make me
nervous because Baker Mayfield was
really good and then he turned out to be
really bad and a new coach in there and
off new offensive minded person in there
but I still have to I got to acquiesce
to those wide receivers and I just don't
know if you can do that in the team
concept Mary Kay I think it can be done
once again with the right coach this was
not the right staff to try to manage or
handle that situation they just were not
a
to the task but you know if you get
someone in there that knows how to
handle an Odell Beckham jr. Jarvis
Landry Baker Mayfield and get those guys
all pulling in the same direction
especially on game day hmm
I said I think it can work but I do
think that they should probably take a
hard look at it yeah I I just I'm
suspicious with that like the Giants got
rid of Odell Beckham because they were
gonna have a quarterback in a similar
situation to Baker Mayfield and Daniel
Jones was probably going to go out of
his way to make sure that Odell got his
touches and you can I've had as much
offensive skill position players as
anybody in the league if you start to
think of it you've got two really good
running backs you got two really good
wide receivers and you had a good tight
end and Joe ku and then you got Baker
coming off that rookie season and and I
know that's why everybody fell in love
with him but man I just I wonder about
the the wide receivers there I don't
know I do well you know what I mean it's
a valid concern I also because they both
make a ton of money and they're sort of
a package deal they're so excited to be
together Jarvis and Odell so I think you
can almost look at it globally and think
okay are we going to start over with
young receivers or are we going to try
to move forward with these two guys and
see if we can make it work with a really
good coach I'm sure we'll be in touch
Mary Kay always interesting there in
Cleveland and maybe we'll get to talk
about something good for a change one of
these days I'm sure we will thank you
Mary Kay thanks Mary Kay Cavett
Cleveland Plain Dealer
Cleveland calm for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]